[Music]
it's no secret that humans are the
Earth's most dominant species and
without proof of life anywhere else in
the universe we can probably consider
ourselves the most dominant species in
space - but what if there were others
just like us millions of years ago how
do we even know that we're the first
advanced civilization to call the planet
Earth home and if there have been others
what kind of traces have they left for
us to find this is what if and here's
what would happen if an advanced
civilization had already existed on
earth
we know that complex life has existed on
earth for about 400 million years but
how could we look that far back ancient
ruins and artifacts only take us back a
few thousand years geologic records only
about two million so if we can't rely on
direct evidence then where else could we
find traces of a potentially extinct
civilization and what can we learn to
make sure we avoid the same fate here
are some numbers to make your brain hurt
for a second the universe is about 13.8
billion years old the earth is
four-and-a-half billion years old and
humans have only developed our
industrial civilization in the last 300
years with all that in mind it seems
like there was ample opportunity for
another advanced civilization to emerge
and flourish and die all before we even
showed up
but finding any proof of a past
civilized species seems like it could be
harder than even starting the
civilization itself physical artifacts
would be the most concrete evidence of
past intelligent life but it's not very
likely that we'll ever find any overtime
even our tallest buildings will crumble
and our strongest materials will
disintegrate our cities cover less than
1% of the Earth's surface so any
comparable cities from past
civilizations would be easy for
paleontologists to miss even if we knew
where to look it's unlikely that these
artifacts would last any longer than a
few million years sure there's always
fossilization but it only provides a
limited record of the past due to
variables like when they lived and where
an industrial civilization that lasted
100,000 years that's over
a hundred times longer than us they
might leave no fossil trace at all so
maybe we're better off looking for more
indirect evidence the best way to find
that would be to look at what traces our
own civilization would leave behind if
it collapsed in its current state one
place we're leaving a clear trail is in
the sediment to the bottom of our bodies
of water one look at this stuff and you
would immediately see the wacky chemical
balances that would imply some sort of
outside influence
for instance the nitrogen fertilizers
that we use to grow food are running off
into our bodies of water and producing
low oxygen dead zones that would be
visible in sedimentary layers on top of
that we'll be leaving long-lasting
synthetic molecules from radioactive
fallout steroids and all the plastic we
dumped in the ocean so yeah future
species are going to have a great
impression of us in case we're not
embarrassed enough our technological
advances are rapidly changing the
environment which is brought on
widespread extinctions that would be
visible at fossil records ironically
perhaps the most promising marker of an
advanced civilization could be one of
the very things that brought on its
downfall when we burn fossil fuels we're
releasing carbon back into the air
fossil fuels ultimately derive from
decayed plants and animals which contain
a variety of carbon that has a different
atomic mass than most carbon in our
atmosphere when this kind is released it
changes the molecular makeup of the
atmosphere and leaves a clear signal to
future scientists in a 2018 study
scientists hypothesized that
civilizations could even have fossil
fuel driven life cycles when fossil fuel
use leads to climate change the oxygen
levels decrease in the ocean and help
create a breeding ground for new fuels
like oil and coal in this way a
civilization and its demise might sell
the seed for new civilizations in the
future in our search for intelligent
neighbors from the past we may never
actually find any evidence but we can
learn a lot about ourselves analyzing
our own long-term ecological footprint
can have practical benefits it helps us
recognize where we can do better to
achieve a balance with our planet so
that we don't become The Forgotten
civilization of tomorrow while it
doesn't seem likely that intelligent
life was here before us that doesn't
mean there wasn't any for all we know
they were so advanced they were able to
clean up the
as they went the only verifiable way to
check if someone was here before us
might be to rev up a time machine and go
see for yourself but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]
you